if i interview putin
what should i ask him how's the cancer
how's it doing buddy
that's question number one in russian do
you think he has cancer
i don't think so that the narrative is
terrifying right
dictator of the largest nuclear arsenal
in the world who also has cancer and he
just invaded a sovereign country that's
a terrifying narrative because that's
what we're all afraid of someone has
nothing to lose who just
decides to let loose a nuke well i do
think
maybe it's projecting but
if i had cancer or if you think about
leaders that have cancer you're facing
your mortality
i would think you'd be
more focused on his legacy and
the dropping nuclear bomb is not good
for legacy i i do believe he wants to be
remembered as a great leader as a lot of
leaders do as a lot of even dictators do
and i think
he wants to figure out a way
to pull out a win so he can
say that
whatever this thing was whatever this
invasion was
was good for russia it was good for the
nation he ultimately made it a greater
nation than it was before and perhaps
you could justify an escalation of war
to be that
but i don't
um and it's just the cancer thing
concerns me so much because it's been
so often part of this propaganda has
been told about putin that he's sick
right i don't know why that it's always
people kind of wonder that a lot about
especially dictators but you had that
even like
with hillary clinton and obviously with
biden
that narrative is stickier so for some
people well that narrative is
transparent yeah obvious but the degree
of it is a question of blindness
with with everyone like what's you know
how healthy is this leader that's the
question people sure always they were
doing that about trump too
um the thing about putin though is like
his uh appearance
is altered where he looks very bloated
his body doesn't look much bigger but
his face looks like puffy and swollen i
had a friend
who had sarcoidosis
and they prescribed prednisone which is
a type of a steroid and one of the
things that would happen when he was on
it is he he would his face would get
really big it was like
he would blow up like a swell up and
maintain a lot of water and
inflammation
and
that's what it looks like what i'm
looking at so actually like if you're
sitting with him one question is about
health that's has as has biden been
asked that kind of question
no like without mockery you'd have to go
on fox news like the mainstream media
treats him with kid gloves in a way that
i've never seen
i mean it's it's so obvious there's
something horribly wrong with his
cognitive function well i i to push back
i don't know if it's horribly wrong you
don't think it's probably wrong i think
it's no i think there's uncertainty to
which degree
is wrong i i would love to there to be a
serious like conversation about it with
him in fact i actually have to now look
because of course fox news will mock
his like
decree declining yes mental health and
then
i would love like sort of an objective
discussion are you aware of this are you
uh like what are you putting in place
are you yourself because if i was a a
person with a declining mental abilities
like you have to start um
you have to start thinking about that
kind of stuff like who is around you who
are the advisors what if you start stop
being able to see the world clearly yeah
i would be transparent about that kind
of stuff well you would be but you also
would never be a politician yeah because
you're too [ __ ] honest
well
yeah but actually from a conversation
perspective it would be nice if that
kind of discussion was had it would be
uh but all jokes aside with putin um
i would ask questions about
democracy versus
what they have i mean without without
any disparaging descriptions of what is
going on
over in russia it's clearly not a
democracy
um
it's
they i mean the way he has it set up the
elections are a joke he's so he would
push back that's not clearly not
democracy he is still very popular so
majority of people are huge supporters
of putin inside russia the he would
the the people that push back against
that would say that that's because
any serious opposition is pushed out of
the country yeah so compensation
murdered yeah so but yes that's a really
really good question
the value of dictatorships one of the
things about the united states that's
fascinating to me is that every four
years unless it's uh it's four to eight
years right
someone does two terms but every four
years
there's an opportunity for someone to be
new
and completely inexperienced at the most
difficult job in the world
which is ridiculous so the interesting
thing is
it actually makes sense after eight
years you've gained the wisdom yeah you
would actually be a pretty good leader
to keep going yeah but there is some
problem where you the power gets started
getting to your head yeah and so like
from putin's perspective
i think he genuinely wants the best for
russia i don't think he's lost his mind
in terms of like it's all about greed
and so on uh same as stalin i think
stalin until the end of his days wanted
the best for the soviet union so it's
not like you become hitler i think lost
his mind during the war like where it
was like he wasn't seen clearly at all
what putin believes is that he is
actually the best person to bring out
the best
for his country now the problem is
maybe
refreshing the leader is in fact in the
long term the best thing versus every
leader believes they know what's best
for the country my point is to keep
refreshing it
well and that's the case for democracy
that's the case for the system we have
that creates uh natural maybe emergent
balance of power
i think it makes it evident that there
is no clear-cut real right way to do it
and that if you have the perfect person
in
having them for 12 20 years would be
amazing if you had a perfect
benevolent leader who clearly only cared
about the people was doing their best
and striving hard and got great
satisfaction knowing that he is
a dedicated civil servant that only
wants to lead the country in a way
that's going to benefit the most people
in the most profound way
but
we have a dirty political system that's
completely corrupted by money completely
corrupted by influence
the fact that
you know the lobbyists i mean there's an
area outside of washington dc it's one
of the richest areas in the country and
it's where the lobbyists live there's so
much money involved being a lobbyist
there's so much money involved in
special interest groups and
how much of an impact they have on
who gets elected and what decisions get
made once that person gets elected we
know this right we know it's not for the
people by the people it's just not what
it is i mean this country is an
experiment self-government and
if we could do it all over again i would
say the most important thing is to have
laws in place to keep money out of
politics
and to make it a heinous crime for
someone to influence
laws
and and
policy
based entirely on the amount of profit
it could generate for a party or for a
company that is uh investing in a
candidate that's [ __ ] incredibly
dangerous and it's corrupt and that
corruption has been accepted we've just
accepted that it's this corruption
exists
you know
last question if putin asks to see this
watch what do i tell him
what would you give it would should i
should i let him see it because we know
what happens with the super bowl ring i
think a super bowl bring is unique he
could buy a watch like that yeah pretty
easy you know but this particular isn't
that a power move
yeah this is the watch you gave me yes
there's a story yes i would probably
share it with him
the story and then maybe go look can i
see this watch yeah and then he puts it
on and says thank you you say no
uh you go like this yeah there it is bro
so many words i'm gonna have to find
translations buddy bro
um i guess bro's brother i mean if he
takes your watch i'll buy you another
one if queen steals it
keep them going i just i'll just give
you the same exact watch
you